And this is what behavior therapists do.
They decompose your problems.
What are you afraid of?
Well,
okay,
you're afraid of everything.
Well,
let's get something specific you're
afraid of.
Well,
I'm afraid of an elevator.
Okay.
An elevator.
So I have a client,
she's afraid of elevators.
The elevator door open.
She goes,
that's a tube.
And I thought,
oh wow.
I thought it was an elevator.
But for you it's not a bloody elevator.
It's death.
And so that's what you're afraid of.
It's worse than that.
You're afraid of being trapped inside
there in the dark alone,
alone,
not knowing if anyone is going to rescue
you,
stuck there with your damn imagination
freaking out.
It's like.
And if that's not,
and then maybe you have a heart attack
because you're so terrified and you die.
It's like,
you know,
so that's the elevator.
Well,
it's no bloody wonder.
No one's going to get into something
like that.
And then maybe underneath that is your
distrust in the mechanisms of society,
right?
Because you know a normal person that
was weird creatures,
they'll get an elevator.
What the hell?
They don't care.
And partly it's because they have an
implicit belief,
even if the thing stops,
somebody will come along and rescue them
and usually you don't even think about
it,
right?
It's like,
wow,
what the hell?
It's an elevator.
So like
the danger is invisible to you
and it's partly because you implicitly
trust the structure and so maybe you go
into the unconscious presuppositions of
the person who is terrified of the
elevator in the subways and you find out
they have a real problem with trusting
authority.
That's partly why they don't get along
with her husband and why they'd never
been able to stand up for themselves.
So then you say,
okay,
while you're afraid of the damn
elevator,
but it's not an elevator,
it's a tomb.
And the tomb is partly you.
And partly it's partly the elevator and
partly your unconscious mind.
And so well,
what can you handle?
Can you go and look at an elevator from
10 feet away?
It's like,
yes.
Okay.
How about nine feet away?
Yes.
Five feet.
Four feet?
No.
Okay.
No problem.
Four and a half feet.
We're going to go from that elevator and
we're going to look at the damn thing
until you're bored of it because that's
what we're trying to.
You should be board of the elevator
because then you're not afraid of it.
Obviously.
It's like an elevator.
You just don't notice it.
Right?
All of these things around here that you
don't notice.
I'd take you out of here and ask you
what color the walls are.
You haven't got any idea.
You know,
I,
I suspect for most of you,
there's not a chance you'd be able to
identify the gender of the person who's
sitting next to you unless you know
them.
It's like you just don't remember
anything and why should you?
Everything works like you don't have to
pay attention to it.
It's like,
does that stay up?
Yeah,
it's still up.
Yeah.
Still up.
It was like,
really?
No,
you know,
you get bored of that real quick and so
then you just ignore it and.
But the agoraphobic has had that veil of
ignorance torn away and what they see
behind it is mortal threat.
And so that's really what you're helping
them deal with.
And so this week there are four and a
half from the elevator.
Next week they're a foot from the
elevator and the week after that the
horrible gates of hell opened and they
look inside and they don't run.
And so,
hey,
they're tougher than they thought they
were.
And that's what you're teaching them.
Actually you're not teaching them that
the world isn't dangerous because that's
a stupid thing to teach someone bloody
right?
The world is dangerous.
It's terrifying.
And sometimes people under a realize
that and the veil lifts and they see
horror everywhere.
They see that and then they think,
well,
I'm just a little rabbit.
I'm over here in the corner.
I can't move.
I'm petrified.
And then they can't move.
They hide it home.
The cower at home because everything is
become a predatory domain.
And so what you teach them is you're not
as much of a rabbit as you think.
And part of that is that you help them
grow.
Some teeth so that they can go home and
have that fight with their husband that
they should have had 25 years ago and it
happens very frequently with agoraphobic
clients that you get them so they can go
on the damn elevator and they can go on
the subway,
they can take a taxi.
It maybe they learn to drive.
Wow.
That gets some autonomy and then they're
a little tougher and so then they can
stand up for themselves and they go back
and like their husband might not be very
happy with any of this really.
It depends on what sort of guy he is.
You know,
if he's a real tyrant,
he might be just perfectly happy that
he's married to someone who was afraid
of her own shadow because then she won't
ever leave.
And so that's a nasty little story and
believe me,
it's not uncommon.
So she gets tougher by facing what she
fears and what she finds out is there's
a hell of a lot more to her than she
thought.
And that's really what happens when you
do behavior therapy with someone who's
agoraphobic.
It isn't really that they get less
afraid,
it's that they get braver.
That's way different.
It's because brave is alert and able to
cope.
Naive is there's no danger.
It's like hell,
you have right?
There's no danger.
Jesus.
What a stupid theory that is.